hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich möchte heute mit meiner
eisfreie weitermachen und zwar gibt es
heute den zweiten teil
ich habe heute ein grundrezept für
sahneeis und zwar habe ich dieses mal
auch mit eiern aber diesmal wird die
masse vorher kurz gegart und zwar möchte
ich heute zeigen wie man max larry
herstellen kann
aus diesem grund rezept hier habe ich
zum beispiel einmal die version mit kit
kat und ich zeige euch später noch eine
ganz außergewöhnliche sorte und zwar
wahllos rucola balsamico
nein waren sie das silikon balsamico war
auch denkbar
ich zeige ich jetzt aber einfach mal das
grundrezept und dafür die zutaten für
das grundeis braucht ihr 300 milliliter
milch dass ich einfach eine vollmilch
200 milliliter sahne 80 gramm
puderzucker nämlich gern puderzucker
weil der sich schneller auflöst und 3
eigelb und benehmen senioren zur
beschlossen
dann dürfte einfach laktosefreie
produkte benutzen also laktosefreie
sahne und laktosefreie milch zu es gibt
jetzt die sahne und die milch in einen
topf und wetzlar höchster stufe erhitzen
aber nicht kochen lassen
in der zwischenzeit gebe ich mein eigelb
und den puderzucker in meiner
küchenmaschine und wertes verrühren bis
sich der zucker komplett aufgelöst hat
das geht natürlich auch ohne
küchenmaschine jetzt ist es ganz wichtig
dass wir das temperieren deswegen gebe
ich jetzt löffelweise die heiße milch
mit zum 1
wenn wir zwei direkt zur sahne mit ge
eingeben würden dann wird sie natürlich
gewinnen und so wird es auch jetzt
temperiert und dann gebe ich das mit der
milch zusammen zurück in den topf das
ganze wird bei geringster stufe verrührt
und gebunden und es dauerte etwa fünf
bis acht minuten dann müsst ihr auf
jeden fall darauf achten dass es
wirklich die geringste stufe ist das
dauert ein bisschen aber ihr werdet
dafür belohnt falls ihr schokoladeneis
machen wollt könnt ihr einfach zu der
milch masse vor dem kochen eben etwas
schokolade mit dazugeben ich hab jetzt
bitterschokolade genommen
und dann verscharrt ihr einfach weiter
also wieder mit dem temperieren und dann
wieder zurück in den topf das ganze
könnt ihr übrigens auch mit einer
vanilleschote aufkochen dann habt ihr
vanilleeis und jetzt könnt ihr zwei
tests machen um zu erkennen ob die masse
fertig gebunden ist einmal mit dem
finger über den kochlöffel fahren oder
eben einmal pusten
das heißt ihr könnt einmal diesen test
machen mit dem posten
und wenn sich darauf dann so eine rose
bildet wie ihr eben gesehen habt dann
ist die masse perfekt gebunden oder eben
einfach da schnell test mit dem finger
und wenn dann eben die bahn zwischen
drin so getrennt bleibt dann ist die
masse perfekt gebunden und die fülle ich
jetzt in der schüssel um ein papier ein
denn dieser masse muss jetzt erstmal
abkühlen bevor ich sie ihren ice gefäß
gebe da mache ich den deckel drauf und
lass das jetzt auf kühlschranktemperatur
abkühlen und danach kommt diese masse in
meine eismaschine und falls ihr keine
eismaschine macht könnt ihr mal bei
meinem letzten video vorbeischauen da
habe ich nämlich die methode gezeigt wie
man eis ohne eismaschine herstellen kann
ich habe jetzt hier noch ganz viel
eiweiß übrig ich habe es heute nämlich
glaube ich fünf oder sechs portionen eis
gemacht damit ich euch die ganze
vielfalt zeigen kann
schmeisst eure weise auf keinen fall weg
ihr könnt ihr damit zum beispiel die
baiser massen machen also diese baiser
oder dem die pronova torte die ich euch
mal gezeigt habe ich finde das ganz
schrecklich wenn menschen lebensmittel
wegschmeißen
gerade wenn sie von tieren kommen finde
ich also ja dass ich seine das finde ich
respektlos einfach gegenüber
lebensmitteln deswegen schmeißt ihr das
nicht weg ihr könnt ja dann mal in der
infobox schon dafür linke ich euch
einfach die videos bzw die rezepte was
er damit machen könnt oder ihr benutzt
es einfach morgen früh zum frühstück
könnt da noch einschlagen oder zwei und
könnt eben damit ein bisschen rührei
machen auf keinen fall weg schmelzen die
kühlschrank alte eismasse wird dann in
die eismaschine gegeben
und falls ihr keine eismaschine habt
geht es natürlich auch ohne da habe ich
letzte woche ein video gezeigt
und bei mir hatte so etwa 20 minuten
gedauert bis die creme fertig war
ich bin jetzt die konsistenz vom eis
richtig super weiteres aus dieser
eismaschine rausnehmen und noch einmal
ganz kurz kühl stellen also wenn ihr ein
mac flury macht dann ist es eher so ein
bisschen cremiger durch diese ganzen
zusätze die wir dann dazu geben also zum
beispiel oreo kekse oder kit kat oder
smarties
aber ich geh jetzt trotzdem noch mal
kurz die tiefkühltruhe weiß bei uns hier
der küche einfach auch sehr warm ist
jetzt mein mac flamme herzustellen
brauche ich natürlich mein 1 das hat
jetzt diese konsistenz wie ihr sehen
könnt richtig schön cremig und weich
also nicht zu hart so soll es ja auch
sein
ich werde das jetzt allerdings noch mal
kurz ins gefrierfach stellen wie sich
die süßigkeiten vorbereitet habe ihr
könnt es natürlich euer mac flury mit
den süßigkeiten aufpeppen die ihr
möchtet ich habe zu viel süßigkeiten und
zwar habe ich mehr folgendes ausgesucht
ich hab hier einmal oreo kekse smarties
da habe ich nicht gefunden also habe ich
hier diese milk art einmischung und
kitkat da ist es eigentlich egal welches
süßigkeiten ihr nehmt ich nehme dafür
gerne gefrierbeutel mit einem tipp
verschluss gibt da meine süßigkeiten
hinein und kann sie dann schön klein
machen
das geht am besten mit seinem
kartoffelstampf bar oder auch mit einem
nudelholz oder einfach mit einem großen
topf und dazu kenne ich sie nicht ganz
so dass sie so cool fertig werden
sondern ich las richtig schöne große
stücke auch mit drinnen damit man auch
was zum beißen hat
ich verteile mainz auf vier schälchen
weil ich heute alle vier sorten zeigen
möchte und gäbe dann jeweils von diesen
süßigkeiten mit dazu
ich gebe es noch mal ein bisschen eis
mit dazu weil meine portionen klein
wurden und verrühren das ganze dann
miteinander und schichte es dann ins
glas
so sieht jetzt das fertige eis aus und
das muss man natürlich gleich verzehren
weil es ansonsten weg schminkt durch die
ganzen komponenten da drin
und jetzt möchte ich euch einfach mal
zeigen wie man noch dieses rucola
walnuss basilikum eis macht und zeigt
euch das ist einfach an der
küchenmaschine ich habe es bereits die
wahl müsse fein gemahlen und habe auch
rucola dazu gegeben und auch etwas
basilikum die genauen mengenangaben
gibt's dann auf meinem blog und das
ganze wird miteinander vermischt und da
kommt dann die kalte als massa mit dazu
das wird noch mal schön cremig gerührt
und das muss dann in den kühlschrank bis
die masse schön kühlschrank kalt ist und
dann kann sie zu 1 zubereitet werden
entweder mit der eismaschine oder eben
ohne 1 erschienen
ich habe jetzt hier mein fertiges rucola
wahllos eis und basilikum eis und es ist
wirklich sehr lecker ich habe das jetzt
noch mal in die gefriertruhe ist falls
hier drin sein warm ist
so sieht es jetzt aus und ihr seht ich
hab das nicht ganz vermixt deswegen
nicht ganz einheitlich eine masse aber
ich finde es so genau perfekt und ich
habe jetzt hier noch so ein paar
eistüten habe jetzt leider keinen
eislöffel weil wir den vergessen haben
aber ich probiere das jetzt einfach so
dass sie ganz schlecht aus oder jetzt
richtig noch in so ein kleines gläschen
an
du hast schon die hand ausgestreckt gut
und dann decke recht einfach mit etwas
basilikum weil mein mann die deko
aufgegessen hat meine rucola tico
ihr könnt direkt aus allem eis machen
also aus allem was euch schmeckt ihr
könnt auch weißwurscht eis machen usw
er sagt jetzt vielleicht gott was ich
das wenn die eissorte aber diese idee
von dem rucola wagens eis habe ich von
dem verrückten eismacher den habe ich
nämlich vor ein paar monaten
kennengelernt und decision eismacher aus
münchen
da möchte ich unbedingt auch mal
hinfahren und ich habe bei ihm ganz ganz
viele leckere eis sorten probiert wie
rucola wahllos und ach gott hat ganz
viele außergewöhnliche sorten
ich mach euch mal vor statt gekleckert
ich stelle euch mal den facebook link zu
ihrem unten in meine info box da könnt
ihr mal vorbeischauen da gibt es auch
einen ganz tollen beitrag bei youtube
über ihn und ich würde sagen ich lasse
mir das eis schmecken das schmeckt
wirklich sehr lecker auch wenn es nicht
original wie beim eismacher schmeckt
aber dieses ei sich einfach wirklich der
wahnsinn mit rucola und walnuss und alle
kritiker die jetzt sagen das schmeckt
nicht das schmeckt wirklich sehr gut
und ihr dürft ihr gerne auch mal
schreiben falls jetzt auch eigene
kreationen entwickelt hat und wie ihr
euch zum beispiel auch das eis von der
letzten woche geschmeckt hat ich wünsche
euch auf jeden fall noch ganz viel spaß
ich stelle alle rezepte natürlich auf
meinem blog auf www.welt.de und nächste
woche wird am mittwoch ein verbraucher
bildungs video kommen und zwar über das
thema gluten und wenn ihr euch mit dem
thema auskennt oder vielleicht habt ihr
schon mal was darüber gehört selbst
betroffen
dann schreibt man das doch gern mal in
die kommentare rein und ich bin schon
ganz gespannt darauf wie ihr das video
am mittwoch finden werdet ich wünsche
euch einen ganz schönen tag bis bald wir
werden es am mittwoch klären
und bevor ich es vergesse es kommt jetzt
auch die fußball-wm und dafür wird
natürlich auch bei mir torten geben
viele tolle grillrezepte vielleicht
möchtet ihr euch da auch was wünschen
rezepttipps kuchen torten muffins und so
weiter in meinem shop werde ich da auch
ganz viele tolle artikel einstellen
es hat kleine cupcake rapper und so
weiter alles mit den nationalflaggen und
so weiter und was wollte ich noch
nein aber ihr wisst ja dass ich fußball
spiele vielleicht habt ihr das mal bei
facebook gesehen ich habe auch bald
wieder unser fußball turnier nur konnten
wir dieses jahr noch gar nicht üben und
trainieren
ich hoffe das sieht jetzt die konkurrenz
mannschaft nicht aber wir trainieren
natürlich sehr hart
deswegen so sieht übrigens fertige
schoko eis aus ich hätte es jetzt noch
ein bisschen länger kühle müssen aber da
wir hier heute noch die küche verlassen
wollen es ich das jetzt einfach so und
bindet es richtig gut durchkommt wird es
natürlich auch sehr gering
schmeckt auch gut mit weißer schokolade
die flugkapitäne
tempo vorgelegt
ist
orschel korrekt gesagt ich hole sie
schließlich herumgelegen
dann gib mir basilikumblätter
dass man ständig die deko weckesser darf
ich außerdem sind es ist besser man das
hat noch das was hat sich muss doch
immer dekorieren
ja ich wollte das eis